Matthew 18:
14-35 write that down we're going to
look at it because he talks about
forgiveness now here's one thing I want
you to understand what our Lord Jesus
Christ teaches about
forgiveness he didn't emphasize this and
I metant many people who don't emphasize
this and may give a misleading
understanding picture of what it means
to
forgive there there's forgiveness on two
levels follow with me and I'm asking the
Holy Spirit to save me from error and
stammering and Grant me Clarity of
thought to glorify Jesus Christ and not
misinterpret scripture and mislead you
okay there
are how do I say this there
is not two types of forgiveness or two
layers but two
levels there is the
Forgiveness that takes place within you
where within you you ask the Lord Jesus
to to heal your heart to forgive that
offense release you from it so you don't
come into bondage to it be enslaved by
it and snared by it and have bitterness
and hatred because of it but then
there's that level of forgiveness where
it's external right where you forgive
the person who's committed the offense
now when you listen to this sermon he's
going to focus on that level of
forgiveness that's
internal within you to be released by
that bitterness or that hatred because
of that offense so you don't be ens
snared by it enslaved to it and it
consumes you and destroys your
relationship with the Lord Jesus Christ
and robs you of your peace the sermon
will focus on that
okay so I want you to listen to
it but then there's that level of
forgiveness where it's not
simply forgiving someone
in your heart so you're
released right from
any hatred and bitterness that may
spring up and enslave and ens snare
you right but then there's the
Forgiveness that's external where you
forgive that
person and extend forgiveness to that
person and verbalize that forgiveness to
that person are you with me there
because I want to finish the thought
complete the thought complete the
picture because in my
opinion it was
incomplete I'm going to shock you when I
say this because I'm going to prove it
from the words of our God and savior the
Lord Jesus Christ and I'm going to prove
it from the very Parable he quoted from
the very Parable he
quoted you are not to forgive someone
verbally that hasn't asked for your
forgiveness let me repeat this
again it is one thing to forgive someone
internally within yourself within your
heart within your mind within your soul
so that you can be healed of any
bitterness or hatred that may spring up
and ens snare
you it's another thing to verbalize your
forgiveness to that person who's
committed that offense against you the
Lord Jesus says you do not extend
forgiveness verbally to the person who
doesn't ask for your
forgiveness the condition of verbalizing
your forgiveness to the person that's
offended you is if that person seeks
your forgiveness and asks that you
forgive them can I prove that to
you I'm going to use the very Parable
that our lord Jesus used now I'm going
to be using the new English translation
okay Matthew
18 14 to 35 I'm just going to use the
new English translation because it has
some notes that help us understand the
currency the amount of debt how
astronomical the debt was between the
servant and the King right but before I
do that again pray for me the Holy
Spirit loosens my tongue to speak
clearly and passionately and bless you
that he anoints the sound of my voice to
be pleasing to your ears for the glory
of Jesus
Christ let me just read to you the
part that he focused on Matthew 18:21
let me read it to you Matthew 18 21:22
ready then Peter came to him and said
Lord how many times must I forgive my
brother who sins against me as many as
seven times Jesus said to him not seven
times I tell you but seven s times or 70
* 7 okay Do You Hear What what Peter
said how many times should I forgive my
brother seven times the Lord Jesus says
70 times seven in other words it's
simply an expression meaning that you
should always be willing and ready and
able to forgive your brother who sins
against you now if I stop there if I
stop there I don't read what comes
before and after after the impression is
is you are to extend forgiveness
verbally to that brother or sister
that's offended you even if he or she
doesn't ask for your forgiveness no
that's wrong that's reading it out of
context are you ready that's reading it
out of context that's not what the Lord
Jesus
meant if I just read Matthew 18
21-22 that's all I read the impression
if I just read 2122
the impression is I am to extend
forgiveness verbally to the person
offended me by saying look I forgive
you even if he or she doesn't seek
forgiveness from me from me or you the
person offended that's actually taking
it out of context now let me give you
the contextual
meaning let's start at 14 Matthew 1814
to 20 and then we're going to understand
Peter's Point Matthew 18:14 to 20 in the
same way your father in Heaven is not
willing that one of these little ones be
lost now watch if your brother
sins Go and show him his fault when the
two of you are alone if he listens to
you you have regained your
brother see if he listens to you meaning
he admits he has wronged you he sinned
against you and acknowledges his sin
then you've gained your brother but if
he does not listen take one or two
others with you so that the testimony of
two or three Witnesses every every
matter may be established if he refuses
to listen to them tell it to the church
if he refuses to listen to the church
treat him like a gentile or tax
collector discipline him disfellowship
him throw him out of the church I tell
you the truth whatever you bind on Earth
will have been bound in heaven and
whatever you release on Earth will have
rele will have been released in heaven
again I tell you the truth if two of you
on Earth agree about whatever you ask my
Father in heaven will do it for you for
where two or three are assembled in my
name I am there among them then Peter
says verse 21 then Peter came to him and
said Lord how many times must I forgive
my brother who sins against me as many
as seven times did you guys understand
the immediate
context what's the context if a brother
sins against you or a sister sins
against you go and confront that brother
and sister make them aware of their and
if they listen and acknowledge their sin
and repent then you have won your
brother you are to forgive if they
refuse bring two or three other
Witnesses and if they still refuse then
bring it before the church and if they
still refuse to accept responsibility
and accept correction and acknowledge
and confess their sin the church is to
treat them as an unbeliever and throw
them out of Fellowship from the
church you see now you understand that
before I move on to the next
part is that clear as it sink
in because now I'm going to read the
rest of it the parable that our lord
Jesus gives now let's read Matthew 18:21
to35 and we're going to read the parable
now let's read the context pay careful
attention because there's a lot of meat
and I'm trusting the Holy Spirit to save
me from error illuminate us to unpack
the meat for the glory of Jesus now
let's
read again 21
Peter then Peter came to him and said
Lord how many times has I forgive my
brother who sins against me as many as
seven times Jesus said to him not seven
times I tell you but 77 times another
reading 70 time 7 now the parable for
this reason See Now understand the Lord
Jesus is going to give a parable
illustrating forgiveness and if you're
willing to forgive the repentant sinner
for this reason the Kingdom of Heaven is
like a king who wanted to settle
accounts with his slaves as he began
settling his accounts a man who owed
10,000 talents and I'll come back and
read the note from the ne to tell you
how much 10,000
talents actually is so a man owed 10,000
talents to the king a servant owed
10,000 talents to the
king and he was brought to him because
he was not able to repay repay it the
Lord ordered him to be sold along with
his wife children and whatever he
possessed and repayment to be made now
watch did you catch it what did the king
say to do throw him in prison throw his
wife in prison with him and his children
until heays it he didn't forgive him he
punished him deservedly
so right but now watch okay now watch it
then the slave threw himself to the
crown before him saying be patient with
me and I will pray you everything the
Lord had compassion on that slave and
released him and forgave him the debt
when did the king forgive him when he
asked for
forgiveness did you catch
it when did he forgive
him when he asked when he didn't ask
what did the king do to imprison
him threw him in prison him and his
family and I'm going to un pactice step
by step but when he asked for
forgiveness and pleaded for mercy and
threw himself at his feet then the king
showed him
Mercy you with me
there let's
continue be patient with me and I will
repay you everything the Lord had
compassion on that slave and released
him and forgave him the debt not only
will I be patient with you I'll even
cancel your debt you owe me
nothing go ahead you're free now
watch after he went out the same slave
found one of his fellow slaves who owed
him 100 silver coins peanuts in
comparison to what he owed he owed the
king 10,000 talents whereas his fellow
servant only owed him a 100 silver coins
peanuts in light of his as astronomical
debt that he owed to the King which was
humanly impossible for him to pay so he
grabbed him by the throat and started to
choke him saying pay back what you owe
me then his fellow slave threw him down
and begged him just like he did for the
king his servant does for him so the
servant begs him like he begged the king
watch
here be patient I mean I'll repay you
but he refused instead he went out and
threw him in prison until he repa the
debt when his fellow slaves saw what had
happened they were very upset and went
and told their lord everything that had
taken place now watch what the Lord says
then his Lord called the first servant
and said to him evil slave I forgave you
all that debt because you begged me you
see it's
conditional when did he forgive him when
he asked and begged for
forgiveness should you not have shown
Mercy to your fellow slave just as I
showed it to you and in Anger his Lord
turned him over to the prison guards to
torture him until he paid all he owed
again watch the key here it
goes I forgave you all that that because
you begged me notice
forgiveness was
conditional it was conditioned on the
man asking to be
forgiven is it sinking in
now let me finish it 35 so also my
heavenly father will do to you if each
of you does not forgive your brother
from your heart so in the parable the
king is God the
father and there unrighteous servant is
someone who professes to be a Christian
a follower of Jesus Christ but did you
catch it so I think you didn't catch it
and this is where people are wrong when
they only give you part of the picture
and not the full
picture are you supposed to forgive
someone who's offended you within your
heart yes ask the Lord Jesus to heal
your heart to forgive and release that
person why for your benefit because you
don't want that offense to eat you
up so that bitterness and hatred Springs
up and enslaves and ens snares you to
that bitterness and hatred robbing you
of your peace and joy with the Lord and
with others so the Forgiveness
internally is for your
health but extending forgiveness
verbally to the one who offends you is
conditioned on that person asking and
seeking for it if they don't you are
under no obligation to tell tell that
person I forgive you you forgive in your
heart but you don't need to tell them
that until he or she ask for
forgiveness
right let me now prove it to you from
another saying of the Lord Jesus Christ
Luke 17: 3 to 4 so I wanted to complete
the
picture Luke 17
3-4 yes Cynthia why for your healing so
that you don't become ins
snared enslaved to that hatred and
bitterness the reason why you forgive
within yourself for you to be
freed for you to be protected for you to
save yourself from being enslaved to
bitterness and hatred will eat you
up and hinder you from walking in peace
with the Lord and
others now Luke 17 veres 3 to 4 let me
prove it to you now you notice what
Jesus goes on to say Luke 17: 3- 4 take
heed to yourselves if your brother sins
against you rebuke him if he repents
forgive him
well if he doesn't forgive repent you
don't forgive him meaning you don't
extend forgiveness to him verbally say I
forgive
you and if he sins against you seven
times a day and seven times in a day
returns to you saying I Repent you shall
forgive me you see it's conditional
again you see I'm not making it up here
Luke 17 3-4 let's look at it
again Luke 17: 3-
4 One More Time
take heed to yourselves if your brother
sins against you rebuke him and if he
repents forgive him and if he sins
against you seven times a day and seven
times in a day returns to you saying I
Repent you shall forgive him it is
conditional